>> A. AGREE WITH YOU.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN NUNES,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOINING US NOW WITH MUCH
MORE SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS WITH US.
HE WAS, OF COURSE, LEADING
THESE HEARINGS WITH WILLIAM
BARR TODAY.
SENATOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Sean: YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE HEARINGS.
LET'S START THERE.
AND WILL BILL BARR DO THE
THINGS THAT JEFF SESSIONS
DID NOT DO AND THAT THE DEEP
STATE, THAT'S HILLARY
CLINTON, AND ALL THE PEOPLE
WE MENTIONED EARLIER?
>> YEAH.
I BELIEVE SO.
I HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIANS
BUTTERY HAVE CELINE AT LOVE
FBI AND DOJ.
HOW CAN YOU CERTIFY TO THE
FISA COURT ON FOUR SEPARATE
OCCASIONS THAT YOU HAVE
ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO GET A
WARRANT AGAINST AMERICAN
INNOCENCE, THE DOSSIER IS
VERIFIED TO THIS DAY.
IS HE GOING TO LOOK HARD AND
WARM AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI THE WAY
THEY CONNECTED THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION AND THE WAY
THEY STARTED UP THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
HERE'S LONG STORY SHORT.
MR. BARR BELIEVES THAT
POLITICIANS SHOULD NOT
INTERFERE IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
BUT HE ALSO BELIEVES A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATOR SHOULD
THOUGHT BE OUT TO GET
POLITICIANS AND THEY WERE
OUT TO GET TRUMP.
>> Sean: THERE ARE A LOT OF
FORCES WORKING AGAINST HIM.
BUT, FOR EXAMPLE, I KNOW IF
I DELETED EMAILS, ACID
WASHED THE HARD DRIVE I
WOULD GO TO JAIL.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT HE DUAL
THAT BECAUSE EVERY OTHER
AMERICAN I GUESS IF YOU ARE,
INVESTIGATED AND EMAILED IS
THAT WHAT HILLARY HAS TAUGHT
US IT?
I. BELIEVE SHE GOT AWAY WITH
THIS.
THEY WERE OUT TO GET TRUMP.
THEY SAY TO THEMSELVES AND
THEY ARE OUT TO HELP HER.
SO I WANT HIM TO DO MORE
THAN MR. HOROWITZ DID.
EXPLAIN TO THE COUNTRY HOW
IT GOT SO BAD.
I WANT HIM TO TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE FISA
WARRANT APPLICATION PROCESS.
HOW COULD IT GET SO OFF
BASE.
IF THERE WAS A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, I WANT HIM TO TELL
US HOW IT STARTED, WHO
STARTED IT.
I WANT HIM TO CLEAN UP THIS
MESS.
I'M NOT EXPECTING HIM TO
THROW MUELLER OVER.
BUT I AM EXPECTING HIM TO
CLEAN IT UP THE MESS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE INN
THE FNN
THE FBI AND I THIS THE
PRESIDENT PICKED THE RIGHT
GUY TO DO IT?
>> WE NOW KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT RUSSIAN LIES WERE USED.
>> YES.
>> Sean: ALSO AN
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
WAS RIG YOU HAD.
FAVORITE CANDIDATE OVER
ANOTHER CAN DATE.
>> RIGHT.
A STRATEGY IF THAT FAILED.
>> Sean: RIGHT U LET ME MOVE
TO GLIFERTION GOVERNOR LIVES
ARE AT TAKE.
WE HAVE 90% OF HEROIN COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY FROM OUR
SOUTHERN BORAT.
THE PRESIDENT TODAY A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY IS NEEDED
THAT'S FINE.
YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING TO
PEOPLE AND YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH.
WHAT IS IT?
>> WELL, I THINK HE NEEDS TO
BUILD THIS WALL BECAUSE WE
NEED OUT WALL.
I THINK DEMOCRATS ARE BEING
HYPOCRITICAL BECAUSE THEY
ALL
VOL
VOTE I HAD FOR MORE WALL
FUNDING THE PRESIDENT IS
ASKING FOR TWO.
WAYS TO BAILED A WALL.
DO IT YEARSELF ACTUAL
REACTION.
THE OTHER OPTION IS TO GET A
LEDGE A LISTEN SOLUTION.
MOPTION HAS SAID I THE GIVE
YOU.
DEMOCRATS WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT TO FUND THE WALL
ADEQUATELY AND MEET HIS
PRIORITIES IF HE WOULD DO
OTHER THINGS.
MR. PRESIDENT, IF DEMOCRATS
COME TO YOU IN THE SENATE
AND SAY THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU FOR A FEW
WEEKS TO SEE IF WE COULD
1068 THIS PROBLEM, GIVE THEM
THE -- GIVE THEM A CHANCE
AND IF THEY DON'T DELIVER,
DO IT BY YOURSELF.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK YOU
COULD CONVINCE THERE ARE
THOSE DEMOCRATS EXIST?
IN THE SENATE?
>> WELL, THEY HAVE GOT TO
COME OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND
SAY WE ARE WILLING TO WORK
WITH YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, TO
MEET YOUR PRIORITIES AND WE
WANT SOME THINGS, TOO.
BUT WE REJECT NANCY PELOSI'S
IDEA THAT YOU ONLY GET A
DOLLAR FOR THE WALL U IF
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS WILLING
TO COME FORWARD TO WORK WITH
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT FOR A FEW
WEEKS TO IT SEE IF WE CAN
SOLVE THIS, TAKE HIM UP ON
IT AND IF YOU DON'T GET WHAT
YOU WANT -- SHANE SEAN SO
YOU WILL HAVE FIVE OR 10
DEMOCRATS SAY GIVE US A
CHANCE TO DURING ON JOBBICS
OPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
IF WE DON'T GET IT DONE IN
THREE WEEKS YOU SHOULD
DECLARE THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND USE PENTAGON
FUNDS OR OTHER RESOURCES.
>> MR. PRESIDENT IF YOU ARE
WATCHING THIS SHOW I THINK
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS THAT
WOULD WORK WITH YOU THAT WHY
COULD GET A DEAL WITHIN OUT
SENATE.
BYE BYE BY THE WAY IN MY
TRUE YOU DON'T GET A PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP.
KEEP IT SIMPLE.
THE BRIDGE ACT.
YOU WILL NO CITIZENSHIP.
IF DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE
WILL WORK WITH YOU, GIVE
THEM A CHANCE.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
IF IT DOESN'T WORK.
DO IT YOURSELF BUT GIVE IT
ONE LAST SHOT.
>> Sean: FIRST QUESTION WILL
BE ONE DOLLAR NANCY.
THAN THEY WILL WORK WITH
YOU.
NO DOUBT THEY ARE BETTER
ABOUT NANCY AND EXTREMISM.
WHAT IS NANCY GOING TO SAY?
RECOMMENDATION I AM DYING TO
HEAR WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
SAY.